the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to talk about wallets
and SPV and if you don't know what SPV
stands for that will be defined as well
so don't worry first you get your
software that's something of a problem
but like how do you know you got the
right Bitcoin software there can be
issues there but anyway there are
multiple implementations that should be
consensus compatible I often use btcd
which is a version written in go but
sort of the the main implementation is
written in C++ so you get the software
and then you somehow connect to peers in
the network there's there's all these
sort of asterixis which means it's not
completely decentralized you have to
find where to get it you have to find
who to connect you once you do that you
get all the headers which are 80 bytes
each you verify all the work and then
you start getting the blocks looking
through the transactions you replay the
history of the last nine years of the
coin and then you arrive at a UT Exocet
an unspent unspent transaction output
set and it should be the same as
everyone else got right everyone else's
have the same headers the same work the
same transactions they'll get the same
set of who's you know which which coins
are encumbered by which keys as you do
and the idea is it would be very
expensive to you know have different UT
EXO sets because you'd have to do all
that work okay so that's the full band
that's you know how a node works but
what about dealing with actually money
so far we've just looked at okay here's
how to get your node running here's how
to observe the network and come to the
same conclusions everyone else but you
probably want to actually do something
with this right you want to pay people
or get paid those are sort of the two
fundamental functions that this tries to
address so the software that manages
this feature is called a wallet and it's
not necessarily the same software as
what's connecting to the network
downloading and verifying in the case of
Bitcoin core it is although many of the
programmers of Bitcoin core wish that it
weren't and there's sort of a long-term
goal of it'd be really great if we could
sort of pull these two things apart into
maybe separate binaries separate
programs something but they're really
intertwined and it's kind of ugly
but there are other things that that are
separate ok so
wallet software functionality seems
simple right you send and receive money
simple of course you need to resend
money before you can send it so let's
start with that okay so we talked about
receive of we did not talk about receive
addresses we did talk about the script
and how it's a generally used paid to
punky hash where you have you know you
you put the hash of your pub key in your
output script and then in your redeem
script and your input
you put the pub key itself which is then
checked against the hash and then the
signature is verified most likely you've
if you've looked at Bitcoin at all
you've seen these types of addresses
they usually start with one there a
bunch of characters long weird mix of
lowercase uppercase Letten umbers and
letters there's a standard for
converting a 20-byte pub key hash into
this address
so the idea since almost everything is
using the same pub key hash script you
can forget about the op codes like op do
op hash 160 off equal verify because
they're they're always the same and so
it's the standard like okay we're just
taking that 20 byte hash and now let's
convert it to something hopefully
somewhat human readable and writeable so
that people can write it down say it
over the phone
this is the one Satoshi made it's got 58
characters and then the last well the
last four bytes which ends up being like
five or six of the letters is sort of a
checksum where you take the hash of the
first however many letters and then
that's supposed to be like equal to the
next one so hopefully if you type
something wrong it doesn't change the
hash and then you send it to the wrong
place and then no one has a matching key
for that there's a newer standard for
this where all the lowers all the
letters are lowercase that's introduced
actually today in Bitcoin core version
0.16 came out and so there's a new
standard called BEC 32 they they did
some research and they found it was
actually much faster to transmit over
the phone via voice because you didn't
have to say whether things were
uppercase or lowercase which ended up
being very annoying for people one
bigger a little f1 to biggie for it's
annoying anyway but the idea is this is
just this
just an encoding of the 20-byte funky
hash so when you type this into a
program it reads this converts it into a
20-byte hash builds the output script
okay so y'all outputs are all the same
um so this is sort of like a UI thing it
the addresses don't really exist at the
look at the protocol level ok any
questions about addresses clearly ok
we're not gonna put there you know UI
and like usability is super important
but not to the focus yet I've ordered ok
the idea in a lot of cases is you want
to receive money and know that you
received it or somehow interact with
people over computers and you couldn't
put a bunch of addresses on a server but
keep your private keys offline because
if you keep both your public key and
your private key on the same computer
that's kind of a attractive target for
someone to break into your system
because they say oh like you know this
guy's running Bitcoin and he's accepting
payments there might be a bunch of money
in this computer if I can get into it I
can take all the money so one issue that
people ran up against pretty early is
well let's say I generate 10 10 keys you
know 10 private keys 10 public keys 10
addresses put them on the server and
then I run out and I can reuse addresses
but that can hurt privacy because people
can then see that the same you know the
same people are using these keys so is
there any clever way we can generate pub
keys without the private key is there
any given all the fun key stuff we've
talked about could anyone think of any
clever ways to do that ok well pretty
straightforward this is this is called
BIP 32 Bitcoin improvement protocol 32 a
proposal 32 it's actually this is a
super simplified version but this is the
basic idea of what they do they do it
much more involved and complicated but
basically you've got your public key P
big P and some kind of randomized data
randomizer data are and you know oops
sorry your private key is just little P
so the idea is you want to send to an
address you want to generate a new
address well it's just your
plus the hash of our concatenated 1
times G and if you wanted to make this 2
3 you can make this any number you want
and then your private key is just gonna
be your that same public key plus the
hash of our right so you give someone
some extra data which they can throw
into a hash function
use this sort of as a every you know an
own private key and you add it to your
private key so no one you know no one
just knowing this data can spend from it
that's really nice because then the
server can generate arbitrary numbers
this makes sense ok oh yes so in the
last one's big a is a public key it's a
point on the curve little a is a private
key I that should not have a G right so
G is the generator for the group G is
sort of how you convert from a private
key to a public key he just multiplied
by G which is just an arbitrary point
yes so in this case there's sort of two
private keys there's your your standard
private key that you actually just
randomly created this number P multiply
it by G to get big P but your private
key for any particular address does
change right you're adding the hash of
our comma 1 or R comma 2 R comma three R
should be like 32 bytes or something you
know you don't want anyone you sort of
don't what you can do is you can have
the server you you you have your server
and you say hey I'm gonna accept
payments for cookies or shoes or
whatever I'm selling and then you give
the pit the server your public key P and
this randomizer R and you just say the
server go wild make whatever number you
want here it has to be this number
should be fairly small let's say less
than a billion and then when you want to
find how much you've gotten paid well
you can generate a billion private keys
here some reasonable numbers of the
computer can actually do it and you can
generate you know you can just increment
this generate a ton of address
and look for them on the blockchain yes
oh that makes sense at all bit 32 is
actually quite a bit more involved and
complicated this is the basic idea but
they make sort of trees of it and you
can say oh well like you know make
instead of just one level we can make
like a whole tree of these things and
like have different accounts and like
make a really full-featured system in
case people want to use this kind of
thing yeah so you can put public key and
this random data on the server the
server can make addresses as needed
really quickly and what's nice is
observers can't link these addresses
right if you're just looking at the
blockchain you won't see the difference
between like a sub 1 + a sub 2 if this
number and 1 or 2 because it's going
through this hash function you ever see
that to an observer it looks like all
completely different addresses and if
someone hacks into the server and finds
this P point and this our randomizer
well that will allow them to link
everything now they can see oh we can we
can also generate all these addresses we
can see that it's all the same person
but that doesn't let them steal any of
the funds so compromising the server
with this well you lose the privacy but
you don't lose your money so that's a
pretty good trade-off ok other questions
about cool so that's one of the features
for like wallets got to do this ok so
the basic procedure you're gonna request
a payment and you're gonna say hey if
you want this jacket send one coin to
address f8f one to e and it's sort of
important to note that Bitcoin doesn't
solve the problem of people paying money
and not getting what they paid for
right that's out of the scope of this
although there's a lot of people like
you know it should but you know it
doesn't do fraud protection it's like
hey I gave you the coin you didn't give
me the jacket
well Bitcoin worked fine Bitcoin made
the coin move that's that's bitcoins job
the fact that FedEx never delivered your
jacket well that's sort of FedEx or the
retailer or all sorts of things like
that so that's you know I don't want to
say it's not a problem it certainly is
but it is sort of seen as out of scope
it's like you know this is a money
system is his money the dollar you know
your dollar bills don't insure
that you're getting what you paid for
that said there's all sorts of things
that do this kind of thing and do try to
ensure delivery versus payment atomic
sauce HDL sees that we'll talk about
later zero knowledge can improve like
all these different things do sort of
work on top of Bitcoin to try to help
these kinds of things in practice though
if you're actually buying like a
physical jacket that someone's going to
deliver to you there's not really a good
cryptographic proof of jacket delivery
so it's some reputation is involved
right then from the merchants
perspective so I sell jackets I want to
know if someone paid me right I have
something on the website put in your
address ok now pay this address so you
add all your pub key hashes to a big
list in your software you say ok here's
all the addresses I've created they're
all you know these 20-byte pub key
hashes I put them in a map or some kind
of array or some database whatever and
then from then on every transaction I
see on the network I also look at the
output scripts so before when I was
verifying the blockchain I actually
never had to look at the output scripts
until they got spent right so when I was
downloading transactions I would look at
their signatures and look at old you
know the old UT exo's in the UT Exocet
and match him up and verify but where
the money got sent in these new
transactions I didn't really care right
it could have been sending it to zero it
could have been sending it to some weird
address that probably was wrong I there
was no there and I believe to this day
there's still no output validation that
happens in Bitcoin as a consensus rule
because it's not important right where
are you sending the money well wherever
you want and are you able to spend it
we'll deal with that later right if you
want to destroy your money fine I'm not
gonna look at the output there's no
invalid output right there can be an
invalid input which there can be an
output which you can never actually use
but you're free to send to it so that's
sort of one of the you know rules in
Bitcoin however in this new in you know
when we're actually looking at our own
money
the wallet we do look at the output
scripts mainly to say hey is this ours
are we getting paid with this
transaction so you look at every output
script and if you see one that matches
hey we got paid right so you see a
transaction one of the outputs hey look
that 20 bytes that's that's me cool
that's one of the addresses that I have
let me keep track of this this is now
money that's in my wallet um so you keep
track of the received payments you save
them to disk in a similar way to your
addresses you use some kind of database
or map or something something efficient
and then you don't need to save too much
information right you need to save the
out point right the TX ID of the
transaction the index you probably want
to save how much you're my own and which
key it was so the actual 20 byte pub key
hash you could look through all your
keys but it might be nice oh that's my
17th key that I've saved in my database
or something you may also want to save
the height information when it got
confirmed so we're not gonna talk too
much about unconfirmed versus confirmed
today but this can be an issue if you
see a transaction on the network that's
not yet in a block and it pays you okay
I got money but it's not confirmed yet
so have I really gotten money I am able
to use that output to spend somewhere
else but now I've got to sort of chained
transactions neither of which is
confirmed and now the second one can
only be confirmed if the first one is so
that can get ugly kind of quick for
simplicity sake let's just say that you
wait until it's in a block before your
wallet recognizes it most wallets do not
do that but most ones maybe should there
can be a lot of weird attacks where you
say like oh I got money and then since
it never really was confirmed at all
it's pretty easy for someone to double
spent right the whole point of the
Bitcoin system was you can't double
spend because it's got all this proof of
work on top of it it's in a block but if
we show in the UI hey you got a payment
that has not yet become you know gone
into a block well there's no assurance
that it won't be double spent yet
because it's not in the blockchain
but most wallets will show that and
usually they'll make it in like red or
put a little exclamation point or
something to try to indicate like hey
this is unconfirmed but that doesn't
always get across to people so maybe
safer to just not show it at all until
it's in a block okay so yeah you you
sort of amass all these UT exos right
you're running you're you're running
your node you've got all these addresses
you've given out to people and then
every transaction that comes in you look
hey do any of these pay me and sometimes
you'll find one that does which is great
and then you save that to your disk and
great now next I want to spend them okay
any any questions about the sort of
getting money procedure yes the height
is what block its in so like height zero
is the first block you know zeros block
and we're now at height five hundred
thousand yeah usually in diagrams who
goes this way but I guess it could go up
and numbers I don't know yeah so next
you need to spend them the spending is
makes sense right it's not too crazy
let's say you want to send six coins to
someone so what you do is you look
through your set of UT X OS that are
your UT X OS and you try to find thumb
such that the total you know the total
number of coins is over six and then you
use them as inputs and then you add your
outputs so for example I've got two UT x
those these are you know much more
numbers but this one has five coins in
it and this one has three coins so I
received at two different times once I
got five coins for a fancy jacket once I
got three coins for a less fancy jacket
and now I want to buy something and I
want to send it to Bob and I want to
send six coins well I've got eight coins
and my inputs so I'll send them said
coin six coins there's two coins left
over if I don't have this it just goes
to the miners so I create my a new
output which is my change output and
then I send the remainder two coins here
now if it's actually these round nice
round numbers the fee would be zero and
it would probably not get confirmed on
the Bitcoin network you do have to have
a small fee right now
it's really small though it's like a
couple cents now it was pretty high a
few months ago but with this this will
work this is the basic idea so you look
through your UT exo's find some okay
output 6 output to something then you
know once you've built this sign it all
broadcast in the network make sense yep
yep yep
you make generally what you'll do is
you'll make a new private key calculate
the public key hash it make this address
and then add it in here all
automatically you can and some software
does just only use one key in one
address and so it'll be pretty clear
because like the keys for this signature
will be the same as this key that it's
sending to and so then it's really clear
even without doing that it's usually
pretty clear and people can sort of
guess like well either she you know
either alice is sending six coins back
to herself and two coins to Bob or she's
sending six guns to Bob and two back to
herself right or maybe six coins to one
person two coins to someone else
entirely that's pretty unlikely usually
metrics will try to like analyze the
transaction graph and say like oh the
smaller outputs are usually the payments
and the larger ones are the change but
but you don't know so if the if the
addresses are all different yes
the fee is the difference between the
inputs amounts and the output amounts so
in this case the fee is zero because I
got five three you know eight and then
eight here so really what you do in real
life is you'd make this like one point
nine nine nine and then the fee would be
that point all one or whatever that the
miner gets in the coin based transaction
that's another way to try to identify
change outputs if you actually had five
three six and one point nine nine nine
I bet the one point nine nine nine is
going back to yourself right nice even
round numbers are seem like real
payments and then these and if you've
got one sort of bunch of nines at the
end all that was probably just reduced
it a little to make this with the fee
but these are all sort of guesses if
you're if you're a third party observer
looking at a transaction you don't know
this could be two different people or
this could be an exchange and you know
like it's hard to tell but you get some
pretty good guesses there are multiple
thresholds so there's the real a
threshold which right now I believe in
Bitcoin is one Satoshi per byte so I
think we said Satoshi's are the smallest
unit possible a Bitcoin so one coin is
actually a hundred million Satoshi's and
there's no decimal places so that's
there's the you I think so right now the
the minimum relay fee by default is one
Satoshi per byte so for a 250 byte
transaction you need 250 Satoshi's which
is some fraction of a cent maybe more
than a cent now I'm not sure and then
the idea is if you see that a
transaction below that you won't even
relay it to anyone else you'll be like
this is so cheap that I'm not gonna
bother sending it to everyone else I'm
just gonna ignore it but above that one
Satoshi threshold you will you know
accept it verify the signatures and then
you know pass it on to everyone else
you're connected to but that doesn't
necessarily mean it will get into a
block anytime soon
it's actually been really interesting
the last I'd say six months where the
fees
went up enormous ly and you see sort of
this like you know really crazy price in
elasticity where people who were paying
one cent then started paying $0.10 $1
$10 $20 and like and like you I guess
the in it what's also sort of optimist
it made me feel good it's like well
clearly there they were getting 20 bucks
worth of utility out of this because
they're now perfectly willing to pay 20
bucks and they were paying one cent a
few weeks ago that's kind of weird and
then it's now gone back down to like 1
cent but it's if there's it's very
inelastic in that you know there's a
fixed size for how many transactions you
can have per minute or per hour and when
people really want to get in there they
have to just bid everyone else out so
we'll talk about the fee mark it's in a
few weeks and replace by fee and that's
sort of a new evolving thing but it's
been really interesting to see in the
last few months how it's changed tenth
of a cent a hundredth of a cent so ok so
the minimum really thing would be more
like two and a half cents so that's you
know it's not zero that's still a fee
right and you got enough of those and
you start making money but it's also
interesting recently it used to be that
the the initial new coins coming up to
miners was just overwhelmingly the
majority of what they earned and people
would sort of ignore fees as a miner but
then in like December January I believe
miners made more money in fees than in
new coins being generated I'm not sure
if that averages out like there were
definitely weeks where that was the case
or at least days I'm not sure if it's
average of the whole month but but it if
you total aside sorry but this guy site
is like a cool way to look at the fees
so you can see like here's he sort of
organizes transactions by fee rate it's
to low res to really get everything but
it's if you just search for Joe ho Joh
EEO he's he works on Bitcoin stuff and
he made this cool site which is open
and you could ream and run it on your
own note if you wanted to and generate
the same cool JavaScript color readings
and you can see the the fee mark and
they're like from an I'm not into I'm
not like a economist but it is really
interesting seeing like there's there's
clearly market failures occurring here
in that so you can pay so the green you
can pay ten satoshis per bite and you'll
get confirmed in ten minutes or you can
pay a thousand Satoshi's per bite and
you will also get confirmed in ten
minutes
and most people are paying ten someone's
paying a thousand you know it's got the
whole spectrum you've got multiple
orders of magnitude of people paying for
the exact same thing and they can all
see that each other it's it's just a
weird sort of seems broken and and part
of it is just the costs to write the
software if you're like you know an
exchange and you're like everyone's
sending you support requests and let's
have it okay I don't know just just pay
a 500-seat oshi per bite fee and then it
seems to work and yeah we're losing a
couple thousand bucks a day but let's
just not deal with that and I think
that's part of it is that you know
there's a lot of software out there that
just has a fixed fee rate or even a
fixed fee regardless of how big the
transaction is or you know it's there's
a lot of software that years ago
wouldn't have to deal with this issue
because there wasn't really competition
to get into a block and now they do so
it's kind of cool what to look at and
see the history of it but I'll get into
like the into the depth of fees and
stuff and I think two weeks or something
okay any questions about last yeah yeah
well it's in some Dutch or something
just search jo-jo h OE jo ho
he's the get like it's the first thing
on google right yeah jo h OE is his like
dutch nickname or something i don't he's
a cool guy he actually um I think I
talked did I talk there was some
randomness problems at some sites
he stole a bunch of bitcoins and gave
them back to their owners like he found
some there was like K reuse like none
sory use vulnerability and some wallets
and so he's like hey look there's like a
hundred bitcoins that I can just take
because I can calculate the private key
and he took him and he was like I think
I know who these are and like can you
prove it and then I'll give him back you
know so he sort of grabs you know
finding a wallet with like thousands of
dollars you know coming out of it on the
street and he sort of grabbed them all
and like tried to get him back to people
so I don't know that I've never met him
but seems like a nice guy anyway that's
how Bitcoin works there's Lee you don't
meet anyone but you see these people oh
he's a nice guy he's a jerk so I'm sure
if yeah I've the weekend was kind of
interesting over Twitter but anyways
yeah okay so you build these
transactions there are issues here
two inputs to outputs that's gonna be
kind of big you're gonna have two
different signatures it's gonna be a
little bit higher fee what would work
better than this it's kind of a silly
question
what would work better than having two
inputs and two outputs to make this
transaction to pay someone six coins
sure yeah that's you could send so
that's actually two slides from now the
next slide was just well what if you had
a UTX over that was acting exactly the
right size then it's easy you just send
them the six clips if you have the exact
right size you TXO and your wallet great
you just send it over it's it's like if
you go to a shop and they're like okay
that's ten dollars for lunch you're like
great I have a ten dollar bill here it
is we don't to deal with like pennies
and quarters and stuff it's annoying so
sometimes this happens it's great
generally well right generally you will
have change in multiple inputs and
outputs and it's kind of annoying so
coin selection is a tricky problem for
CSE you know terms it's np-hard actually
but there's heuristics that work okay if
you have a ton of you TX OS and you have
to send these payments you can't
actually in reasonable amount of time
calculate the optimal way to do it but
you know there's some there's some
heuristics that work okay and the
question is what are we optimizing for
so generally you want to optimize the
minimize the number of inputs used right
so the fewer in the inputs are much
bigger they're gonna be like a hundred
something bytes and the outputs are
pretty small they're like 20 30 bytes so
they're real if you want to minimize
size of your transaction minimize the
number of inputs which is easy right you
just pick your biggest you TXO and spend
that one yes yeah it's basically as you
what because it's multi iteration so if
you're just trying to optimize your
transaction right now you just use your
biggest EXO so for example if you want
like it's sort of in the analogy of
you're at a checkout counter and there's
gonna be you someone says okay that's
you know $12.93 if you want to minimize
the number of bills you're handing to
the cashier you just take the hundred
out of your wallet right that'll always
work and you know and you just say I
take the my biggest bill hand it to you
okay I'm minimizing the amount of bills
I'm handing you and this one transaction
however that could result in a whole
bunch of bills coming back right a bunch
of weird change and then also long term
that doesn't
if your strategies always just just hand
over the hundred or you know go through
your wallet just hand over the biggest
bill you have every time no matter what
they ask
that's super suboptimal because if they
say 1293 and you have a twenty and a
hundred and you hand over the hundred
like why did you do that you know so and
then you're gonna have like four 20s so
it's very similar to that except now
that it's similar to problems like that
except the change and bills have
arbitrary denominations there there
isn't a fix you know you have hundreds
twenty hundreds 50s 20s tens fives now
it can be any number so yeah so if
you're just looking at one time just
pick your big issue at exo you'll have
the smallest rands action but you want
to minimize next time
so you ideally can eliminate the change
output and just get you know perfect
target it's it's actually really
complicated there's really cool research
on how do we select coins for like long
term yeah yep that can work that's not
optic that's a good heuristic right
that's a good like pretty easy to code
you know sort your etx those go here use
that one it's not super it's not really
optimal because then it's a lot better
than picking biggest what do I have in
my wallet so I've actually written an
SPB wallet and like all this stuff just
from scratch and it's kind of
interesting you learn a lot about how it
works
I hate our 'get two inputs instead of
one because then eventually if you do
that what will happen is you're always
you're gonna be using one input which is
great and then you're gonna run out of
you're gonna have run out of big inputs
and then you're gonna always have to
like use two or three and you can get
kind of a lot of dust dust it's dust is
like the sort of colloquial term for
really small UT exos we're like you've
got a bunch of pennies and stuff so
that's one issue
another issue is privacy concerns so
when you use to UT exo's or have two
inputs in the same transaction that's
linking those transactions linking those
two UT exo's it's not definitive right
you can
interactively create transactions with
other people in practice that doesn't
happen right you could say hey I want to
pay Alice five coins and you want to pay
a bob six coins and let's put our my two
year to EXO's and your two York to EXO's
and we'll pay these two people and we'll
put our own change outputs and we'll
sort of mix this transaction together
and we'll all sign it and you can do
that securely that sense you know you
only sign when it all looks right to you
and everyone only signs when it's done
but the coordination problem is pretty
severe right you have to find other
people who want to pay you know make
transactions at the same time that you
do it's annoying so in practice since
you're just using your wallet if you see
a transaction with multiple inputs you
can you can surmise okay those are the
same person or the same company and if
you want privacy if you want to maximum
anonymity what kind of coin selection or
payment strategy would you use and yeah
if someone says hey pay me six coins
okay well I have these three inputs and
I'm paying you two coins here and one
coin here and three coins here and I
paid you six coins but in three
completely separate transactions that no
one does either because it's annoying
you could it would it would be the most
anonymous but even then like well what
if they all happened at the same time
and you see they all get in the same
block and you're like okay well they're
not linked nearly as closely but I am
seeing that these three transactions
happen temporarily similar time so
there's all sorts of things to try to
optimize for okay any other questions
about okay media like short term yes
like if you start out with a bunch of
coins then start using it yes but it
does reach equilibrium right in that
let's say you've got all these little
tiny outputs of like you've got all
these $1 bills
but then you need to buy something that
is 20 bucks you have 20 inputs and one
output and whoever you're sending to now
gets that one big output and so so like
yeah if it sort of vanished compared to
if you graph that over time yeah
initially everyone was getting all their
outputs were 50 coins each right cuz
that's how you mind them and then now
they're getting you know smaller but but
there is sort of an equilibrium once
after you've used it for a while any
other questions about sort of coin
selection you TXO selection yes yeah
yeah so that's that's costly I that's
another reason probably people don't do
this there's I think the biggest reason
is it's just annoying the code and it's
like and and you can have failures where
like here give me six coins okay I'll
give you three two and one oh the three
didn't work but the two and one did well
now what do we like you paid me half of
it like it's nice to have sort of
all-or-nothing
payments so and also we have to send
different addresses you know there's all
sorts of things also it will be higher
fees in practice it's actually not much
higher you don't gain if you if you did
let's say having three one input one
output transactions versus one three
input three output transaction you don't
say too much space most of the space is
taken by the inputs and the overhead for
a transaction is only 10 or 20 bytes or
something so it's not a huge difference
the main difference is that you are
never coalescing into larger output
sizes so you're gonna always have to
sign it so you can have more inputs
overall but yeah this is a really it's a
kind of cool problem there's like a lot
of computer science II stuff but a lot
of sort of heuristics and like how
people use it and also the fact that
fees are variable over time means you
might want different strategies when
fees are low versus one fees are high so
right when fees are low now I should
make or maybe I just make a transaction
to myself
where I condensed all my little
two-dollar outputs into one big thousand
dollar output so that when later on if
fees are higher I want to spend my money
I can do so more efficiently and and
there is evidence of this with like
exchange ins and stuff where a lot of
times fees will be lower on the weekends
because people aren't buying and
spending Bitcoin as much I guess and so
certain companies would say okay over
the weekends we're going to sort of
condense all our UT exos and like
combine them and then we can make
smaller transactions during the week so
there's all sorts of cool strategies
here so it's an interesting topic I
haven't like gone super in-depth but the
guys that chain code work on it I don't
know there's like a lot of discussion
about it so it's kind of cool ok oh and
a little bit behind ok next we'll talk
about losing money and that's another
really important part of detecting the
blockchain it's it's hard to do but you
you have to detect when you've lost
money and it's tricky because just
because you sign the transaction doesn't
really mean your money's gone
you can't just unilaterally say ok well
I'm making this I signed it they're my
money's gone from my wallet well not
necessarily
maybe this never gets confirmed right so
maybe you still have that money so you
broadcast it but you sort of have to
wait until it gets into a block and you
also need to listen for your own UTX
owes even if you haven't made a
transaction and see if they've gotten
spent and why would that be like can
anyone think of reason why I haven't
signed anything as far as my program is
concerned but I might lose money anyway
why would that be yeah sure you get
hacked that's the bad reason a good
reason is well maybe you have the same
wallet on multiple computers right
you've got the same keys and say so this
is getting hacked is sort of a malicious
version instance of this problem where
you know I thought the wallet was only
on my computer but actually someone else
has a copy but even even non maliciously
I've got a copy on my phone I got a copy
on my computer it's the same address as
the same keys the same UTX O's
that's totally doable and then when I
you know spend money with my phone and
get to my desktop my desktop needs to
sort of download and see Oh money got
you know you lost money and it's like oh
yeah yeah I remember spending that so
you can have that you know over multiple
computers so if you're designing wallet
software you do definitely need to make
sure that even if it's sort of
unexpected from the wallet itself and it
doesn't seem like I generated a
transaction you can still can still be a
transaction taking your money way
wallets without Bitcoin and that's sort
of a cheeky fray okay I don't mean they
don't have any bitcoins in their wallets
I sort of mean they're not running
Bitcoin in the same sense that we've
talked of so we talked about running
Bitcoin right where you download the
software you get the headers you verify
all the signatures you build the UT
Exocet can you use Bitcoin without doing
this what do you guys think what's a
simple way to possibly use Bitcoin
without having to do all these things so
like a really really simple way if you
don't want to do work what's the
simplest way to not have to do work
someone else to do it so for example my
dad has Bitcoin but he just gives it
these like you you deal with it so I've
got a couple of bitcoins that's my dad's
I have to make sure like no this is not
my money
yeah get someone else to do it right so
that's sort of a we're gonna talk about
the different ways to get someone else
to do this and what we called before
bit running Bitcoin many now call a full
node and there's also the idea of like a
light node or SPV node which we'll talk
about some people don't really like this
distinction and it's like well wait full
node is running Bitcoin these other
things are sort of you know we shouldn't
have to call it a full node we should
just call this a Bitcoin node and these
other things are like not quite there
but there's a lot a little preface
there's a lot of argument about terms in
this space so there are some people who
say svv doesn't exist and other people
this is an SV v8 it's so people argue
about the words it's
not like we have really nice definitive
terms I'm generally trying to use the
most widely used terms but there's
probably people who'll take issue with
it so sorry
so svv is is sort of a step down below
running a full note in terms of security
it's called simplified payment
verification it's written up in the
white paper on how to do it and you can
verify all the work without doing too
much you know
signature verification or having too
much data so the basic idea is you're
optimizing for not having to download as
much and not having to store as much at
the cost of some security and I'll talk
about those those costs okay so before
we had the sort of list of what you do
for a full note the SPV method is a bit
different right you still do the same
part in the beginning right you'd
connect you get your headers you verify
all the work okay cool
the next step you tell another node that
you're connected to all of your
addresses all the all of the key public
keys that you've ever generated you tell
it to them then you for each header you
go through instead of downloading the
whole block and getting all the
transactions and verifying them you ask
the other node hey did I get any money
or did I lose any money in this block
because I told you all my addresses oh
sorry you also told them all your UT
exos you also tell them here's all my
here's all the money I have here's all
the addresses I could possibly receive
money on did I get or lose any money in
this block and then they will return to
you a merkel proof of the transactions
where they think yeah you got some money
here yeah you lost some money here and
you can verify those yes there there is
none you're not paying them they don't
know who you are there's sort of a meta
incentive in that like you know I run a
node that will provide these merkel
proofs because it's like well it helps
bitcoin and maybe if I have some Bitcoin
and I'm helping other people use it my
Bitcoin will be worth more but that's a
pretty yeah a few sort of thing and it
can be a problematic because because
some of these things I didn't
mention that in these slides but the
server-side can get a little bit costly
in terms of CPU because you're
potentially as a server you're the
client requests hey here's this block
can you sort of filter it for me find
things that I'm looking for see now you
have to load that block in the memory
look through it it's not too CPU
intensive but it can be you know when
you have a bunch of them like a 20 or 30
of them connecting to you I've gotten
you know 30% 40% CPU for doing this kind
of thing to serve other users just at
like a most almost all phone wallet well
many phone wallets and many desktop
wallets are using this model and so
you'll see let me go so for example if I
here's a full node the this building
I actually rebooted it recently so
there's not very many connections
incoming but most in practice ok these
two are Li are like actual full nodes I
bet this is a fake node this is a fake
node this is they're all fake
yeah well sorry these are all know that
one maybe not well you can look but like
a lot of nodes will say they're nodes
and they're not and they're just trying
to track where transactions are coming
from and like keep tabs on you and stuff
and these are SPV notes these bit core
because they never act they don't really
ask for I don't know what they're doing
they're not asking for anything so you
can look through all the messages I
think Ethan will talk about this a bit
more Wednesday but there are a lot of
SPV nodes there's a lot of stuff out in
the network you have no idea what it's
doing it's it's but it's pretty clearly
not running a Bitcoin node so yeah so
I'll go through these steps a little bit
and oh yeah so the merkel verification
we talked about last week I think we're
if there's a block and there's thousands
of transactions in it and this server
wants to prove that one of these
transactions is yours and is in there
say okay here's my transaction they just
need to provide you this transaction ID
this hash and then you're able to see
okay yeah it was in the header right so
my transaction
you're not just making it up I didn't
talk about the good part well the good
part is you don't really need to
maintain aut Exocet and it's pretty
small so it saves space saves time what
are the problems there's a lot and I
definitely admit I before writing my own
SPV wallet code I didn't think there
were a lot of problems with it I thought
it was like oh this is a CV this is cool
this is how wallets work but when
writing the code myself I'm like wait
this is horrible what do we do okay so
the first thing you do is you connect
you get the headers you verify them this
is exactly the same procedure as what a
full node does so there's no difference
it works right no difference there the
next step you tell a node all of your
addresses Wow there goes all your
privacy right because you're just
connecting to a computer you have no
idea who they are who's running it and
you're telling them hey here's all of my
addresses and also here's how much money
I have
right here's all my UT X OS you can lie
you can add things that are not so you
can also add some addresses that aren't
yours or add some UT X OS that aren't
yours and you'll get some some
transactions back that you can then
filter out on your own right so you can
you can raise the rate of false
positives for that server and so there's
these these bloom filters that are in
the Bitcoin code core code that they
said like the idea was well you can sort
of dial your own false positive rate
right I'm not gonna go into our bloom
filters work if you've used those in
other classes cool but it basically sort
of gives some data which allows people
to match things but they don't in
practice have good privacy you can
create a bloom filter where they've you
know got 10% false positive rate and so
when the server says oh looks like their
transaction maybe it's not because 10%
of the time it's just a false positive
however when you have really high false
positives you lose all the efficiency
savings of SPV and it's sort of Cascades
where you've got these false positives
and the server thinks oh you got money
but it's a false positive and they add
that you got
money into the bloom filter itself and
the bloom filter can like really quickly
become saturated then you start giving
you everything so in practice and
there's some papers about how the people
who put the bloom filters into Bitcoin
like oh this is good for privacy it's
fine and in practice it really is not
good for privacy so you end it you end
up basically telling a note all your
addresses and there's there's research
on how to do this in a better way and
it's one of those kind of things where
some random anonymous person with a I
think like inappropriate swear word
email address posted to the mailing list
and say hey why don't you guys do it
this way and it was like oh yeah we
should have done it that way
oops the basic idea is instead of
creating a bloom filter as a client
sending it to a server basically instead
of telling the note all your addresses
and asking what the nodes will do the
full nodes will create a bloom filter
based on the entire block and then the
client can retrieve that match that
against their addresses and see hey then
this block have anything of interest to
me and if so request it much better
privacy at a pretty small cost in
overhead and so just no one thought of
it there's a lot of things in Bitcoin
weird like no one thought of it and we
did something Dahman then something
better came out and now we're working on
that okay so the tell-tell the node all
your addresses that's a problem for each
header ask if you gained or lost you TX
owes so can you think of any problems
here not yeah yeah yep easy to lie you
just don't tell them you know if you're
a server you just omit things and you
can maybe mitigate that by connecting to
a bunch of different nodes but then you
lose even more privacy because you've
now shared all your addresses and money
with multiple anonymous notes but yeah
it's really easy to lie by omission you
know if someone says hey here's all I'm
at my addresses okay did I get any money
yep yep and then you see one where they
got a bunch of money and just don't tell
them and they don't know this can be
annoying in regular wallets in the
Lightning Network stuff that I work on
I'll talk about hopefully later this can
actually be very damaging you could lose
money because of this but in general in
Bitcoin you won't lose money because
you're not aware of a transaction so
this is this is also a problem right
easy to live on mission
the merkel proofs help but they prove
inclusion not exclusion there's no way
to construct a proof that you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you a proof that
I'm not emitting anything although with
the idea of the block based filters
sending there's there are ways to
construct that so it's even better in
that sense okay so these are some of the
disadvantages of SBV can anyone think of
any other problems with it or yeah yeah
okay so yeah you don't know since you're
not downloading the blocks you don't
really know how much fees other people
are paying you're not verifying so even
when you get transactions you cannot
verify any signatures because you don't
have UT Exocet so you just see that it
came from somewhere but you don't know
if the thing it's spending even exists
or has a key or anything so you can't
verify the signature you don't know how
much money was coming in so even if you
look at the transactions you can't tell
what fees they're paying you sort of can
if you download an entire block there's
there's ways around it but it's like
really ugly so it's it can be very
difficult to estimate fees so in
practice you probably ask the same
server that you've told all your
addresses and all your UT X those two
hey what fee should I use then they tell
you that and the idea is well if I asked
five people hopefully most of them will
be around the same so there's a bunch of
problems with SBT
okay so it's TV sounds pretty bad right
and I think I'll stick my phone note but
uh is there anything worse than SPV
asking for a friend
can I can I can I go worse so does
anyone know something we can do that's
that's worse security worse privacy than
SPV it's also very much yeah
okay that's that's even worse but yeah
there's there's a step in between so you
can take out some of these steps where
you just used to have an API and you ask
people you have a website you know
blockchain not info or mycelium wallet
or bunch of all a bit pays a copay
things like that work you don't verify
any headers you don't look at any merkel
proofs you just skip right to the tell
the remote node all your addresses and
you TX OS and ask how much money you've
gained or lost right so you sort of
outsource the entire process you don't
store really anything on your computer
and you say well I've got but you do
have your private keys right you say I
made some private keys I made some
addresses and then I tell this website
hey here's all my addresses how much
money do I have in the server's fronds
yeah you've got UT exo's cool so then
you can build the transaction sign them
and send them on the server so what are
some advantages and disadvantages of
this there's probably some obvious
disadvantages right and then you would
think of an attack this does not help
you against the server can just say hey
you got the thousand bitcoins you're
like awesome but it's just completely
made-up right you you you don't verify
as the client you don't verify anything
about these transactions so that's a
pretty big problem and and the thing is
in practice like one of the issues is
that people are generally not as aware
of these types of attacks because mostly
people worry about spending their money
and they don't really you know merchants
worry about charge backs and worry about
receiving and verifying that they've
received funds all the time but most
people's experience is you know they get
paid once a month or twice a month with
a paycheck and the money shows up in
their bank or whatever and they never
really worry about that and they worry
about spending their money and getting
defrauded or things like that so it's
not something a lot of people think
about all the time is
did I actually get paid so there you
know there's easy fraud that you can do
with this kind of attack vector where
you know you sell a car on Craigslist
and someone comes and says yeah I paid
you the bitcoins but they've actually
compromised the server and you haven't
gotten paid at all but you think you
have you give over the goods so yeah
potential problems they can say you got
paid when you didn't they can say you
lost money when you didn't and if it's
in a browser that's even more fun
because they can change the code without
you know the javascript is not pinned to
anything so if someone compromises that
server they can change the code and
potentially get your private keys so so
you have really very little security the
blockchain is not really providing
anything in this case however this is
one of them this is much more popular
than running a full or svv node because
you know blockchain and info you just
sign in there's a lot of wallets on the
phones that work this way as well and
you do at least have your private keys
right hopefully so you've got that right
you're you're not giving custody in any
sense to them but they learn a lot of
information okay so not even SPV can we
do worse and wait you someone yeah
coinbase
well so the coin base company who is an
example of can we do worse yes you can
someone else's coins is worse the case
where my dad you know said hey can you
hold on to these coins for me it's worse
right he doesn't run a node he doesn't
have his private keys he doesn't really
understand Bitcoin that well he wants to
but he's busy and he's like hey you know
this stuff you deal with it I you know
way more about this than I do
I trust you since you know were dad and
son and stuff so like not a huge trust
problem there so I do it for but you
know banks right you don't even have so
the idea of a site or an exchange or
think something like this where you
don't even have your private keys
you just have a website where they run a
node arrow and a wallet and they owe you
the money it tends to end badly and it
you know even if it doesn't end badly it
misses the point right the whole idea of
Bitcoin was like hey you can sort of
have your own
money it's kind of cool it's running on
your computer it feels like it's missing
the point to just hand it over to some
bank it's not even a bank right most of
these sites a big reason why it tends to
end badly is there aren't the same
protections that banks you know the
banks have to do a lot of work and
there's FDIC there's all sorts of rules
and and they also build these big
structures it's really heavy stone
pillars so you're like yeah they can't
run off because this banks not gonna
move its me other rocks in the banks in
Bitcoin do not have big stone pillars IP
addresses are really easy to change and
just move the computers around another
thing they're running a node right these
these Bitcoin banks that hold all your
funds sometimes they don't
so these banks themselves might run sqv
nodes or API things I don't want to like
name any names but like there's pretty
good evidence that like you know big
exchanges might even just connect to an
API and not even run their own node
another there's a lot of things like
this where when something bad doesn't
happen people just keep pushing it where
miners themselves don't verify the
blocks because they think well you must
have created a valid block and I'm not
gonna verify it and everything works so
the other thing is while well it sounds
really bad
in practice there haven't been really
many SPV attacks or API attacks right we
know of this but in practice it's it's
hard to do right you're if you want to
defraud someone with say the you know by
compromising watching on info you have
to compromise blockchain on info you
don't have to do all the proof of work
because they're not validating it but
it's still hard to do and you know it
requires a coordinated active attacker
with quite a bit of resources and so
when it doesn't happen people say well
sPB's just as good right we don't have
any evidence of people being defrauded
so it's just as good but that is kind of
dangerous because when everyone starts
doing it you start to lose these
protections any questions about the
someone else's coins model
there's all sorts of legal issues
there's a very long list of ways it ends
badly I don't know what what is the
half-life of a custodial exchange in
Bitcoin it's like a year or two and they
they drop off okay so why do people do
this
and here's sort of a table of trade-offs
with these things it's mainly
convenience and so that's you know it's
a real reason to do it so if you're
running a full node you're gonna have to
download at least 170 gigabytes that's a
lot right it's gonna take a while
storage you're gonna have to store at
least 4 gigabytes like long term and it
that's going up but not going up too
much it's actually gone down the last
few weeks that's sort of the UT exocet
right you have to keep track of you
don't have to keep track of this hundred
70 gigabytes it by default does but you
can turn on pruning but that's also
super user unfriendly you have to edit a
Bitcoin comm file and type pruning
equals 500 or something and then save it
and then it'll prune down to four gigs
there's no at least that I'm aware of
there's no GUI nice menu thing where you
can say hey I want to enable pruning I
don't have to store this speed on a
really nice computer it will take at
least six hours to download all this and
verify it it's pretty impressive because
it used to be more but that's still six
hours people don't want to deal with
that privacy okay certainly we can do
better there's a lot of research on how
to make privacy and Bitcoin better but
this is what we got you know it's okay
security okay we you know this is as
good as we've got okay so then you go
down to SBB network you only have to
download about 50 Meg's all those
headers if you've got a wallet with lots
of transactions you're gonna download
100 200 300 Meg's is you're gonna have
to download all the transactions that
you you know that pay you or you're
paying out to speed I said seconds I
think I want to change it to minutes I
don't know it's not it's not that fast
it's it's a lot faster
I think seconds is an exaggeration well
it's like 60 second
it's pretty fast right you download all
the headers that takes the same amount
of time but that can be a minute or two
and then you're sinking the blocks it's
really quick they're small privacy is
poor right you you lose a lot of your
privacy in SPV because you're basically
telling random computers on the Internet
hey here's all my money and here's all
my addresses there's it's not you're not
completely losing everything but but
it's pretty easy for actors to
reconstruct your wallet from that
security medium I don't know it's there
haven't been any real attacks on this
but you're not verifying the rules of
Bitcoin right if everyone's running SPV
then a minor can say hey I just
generated a thousand coins out of
nowhere and no one's looking for that
transaction it only pays me and no one's
gonna see that and reject the block
right so so if everyone runs SPV you're
sort of not checking up on the miners
which is a very real threat like miners
do crazy stuff and you gotta watch out
for that yeah so security question API
query where you just ask a website hey
here's all my addresses how much money
do I have network traffic I don't know
less than a megabyte you have to load
the websites and stuff but it's pretty
light storage you basically don't have
to store anything I mean you have to
store your private keys but those can be
sort of password based and derived on
the fly speed like a second right it's
real quick you're you're making an HTTP
query you're getting a response you're
parsing it it's real quick
privacy is poor it's worse than svv but
because it's like now it's really easy
because they just you just hand them
over over all your addresses in the
clear and security is also quite poor
right in that they can say hey you got
money or you lost money and you just
accept what they say hold my key
this is network traffic I don't know you
have to go to a website I guess there's
no storage there's no speed there's no
privacy there's no security you're just
handing the entire thing off to someone
else so what
what would you guys guess are the most
liked popularity of the different models
most popular least popular yeah this is
definitely the most popular second most
third mouth force mode yeah so it
everyone does this people do this people
do this a couple thousand people do this
it's a problem and this is something
like that is one of the ongoing problems
not just in Bitcoin aetherium if your
name would be a little different but
still it's gonna be a lot of this sort
of weird different SPV there's there's
like other s models there's sort of one
in the middle for aetherium that's also
quite popular oh it's like STV with UT
EXO commitments well I guess it would be
more here anyway I'm not gonna go but
yeah so it's it's a problem and like
there's different ways to attack it like
one of the issues is with a lot of
people who program Bitcoin itself really
only focus on this and they say look
we're not this is not our problem right
like we don't we can't solve this we're
gonna try to make this the way we're
gonna try to solve this is to let's try
to get the speed down right if it takes
days people are gonna move this way if
it takes hours maybe a lot of people say
hey I was using SPV but yeah it's not
too bad running this I'm gonna run this
and get the more security let's try to
keep this number down let's try to keep
you know speed down let's try to improve
privacy and security of the full node
that is generally what most of the
Bitcoin core developers focus on which
you know I don't argue it but it does
lead to some neglect of like the SPV
where there's not you know that it's
been over a year year and a half almost
two years where we know how to make SPV
better and more secure but there's not a
lot of enthusiasm and people working on
it
and people argue about the security of
these things this there's not much you
can do I mean there is kind of
cryptography research like hey how can I
you know is there some cool way I can
send you all my addresses so that you
can figure out how much money I have
without you learning all my addresses
some kind of that's called private
nation retrieval and there's all sorts
of papers on that in practice there
aren't any that used that and this well
yeah multi-sig like have that's more
like regulation right can we have sort
of restrictions and rules on these
essentially banks to try to make it
safer
maybe but yeah this is these are sort of
the two where you know software
development can definitely help you know
make this a lot easier to use and so you
know we can encourage people to use it
but most people since Security's hard
because most people if you don't see a
problem this is a lot easier and a lot
of people think well I'm not good at
computers so they are and it's safer if
I give all my money to someone else in
in some cases it could be true but that
has sort of systemic effects where now
you've got these you know there's like
five computers in the world and if
you're able to compromise those like
they have just billions of dollars worth
of bitcoins on them and so that's why
you know for for blackhat attacker
hacker kind of people it's like the best
thing to do it's like so I was like
there's a computer somewhere and it's
got a billion dollars of like
untraceable money that I can just steal
like it's what could be yeah I could get
everyone's passwords that's cool or like
yeah I could like read people's emails
whatever or I can just steal a billion
dollars like so what do you think
they're gonna do so yeah so this leads
to you know huge concentrations of coins
on in a very small number of nodes and
people try to attack it so this is sort
of the landscape were in now it's
certainly not ideal there's a lot of
technology that's pretty good that's not
being used there's a lot of technologies
scrummy that's being used a lot and you
know how to make this stronger and
faster how to make this faster things
like that are really interesting
research areas working on ok and yeah
almost done wallets are fun big
usability issues try if you want to try
test net wallets you can try downloading
them playing around with them they often
leave quite a bit to be desired the one
work on lit leaves enormous amounts to
be decided there's like it's all in text
and Ethan should be here Wednesday and
good luck with the problem set